Speaker 1: So we haven't talked about
vaccination for a while, and you know, generally
Speaker 2: speaking, I've been aware
Speaker 1: that the U.S. has vaccinated about
60 percent overall. And I intuitively assumed that
there was some kind of Partizan split because of
some of the numbers we've been looking at, but I
Speaker 2: did not realize
Speaker 1: how
Speaker 2: disturbingly horrible
Speaker 1: the Partizan gap is. So let's
go through what we've known for a while.
We've known for a while that there was
probably some Partizan split on vaccination.
We've seen that for the greater part of 2021.
COVID cases, hospitalizations and deaths have
been disproportionately happening in the
Speaker 2: reddest red Trump
Speaker 1: counties compared to the bluest blue
Biden counties. We've seen how the COVID death
rate since vaccines have been widely available is
Speaker 2: about three
Speaker 1: times higher in
the reddest Trump counties
Speaker 2: compared to the bluest Biden counties.
Speaker 1: And again, this came with the
intuition that part of the explanation must be
vaccination rates. Now, I also have said even
in blue counties, it's likely that the deaths
are still skewing towards Republicans relative
Speaker 2: to that county's
Speaker 1: population. We now
have data on vaccination, and it is even
worse than I imagine at this point in time.
96 percent of Democrats say they've already been
vaccinated, while only 54 percent of Republicans
have been vaccinated. There is no. There is
no lesser vaccinated group than Republicans
at this point in time in the United States.
Democrats are getting vaccinated at nearly twice
the rate of Republicans. This is no small detail.
This is from polling done by Monmouth University.
Let's take a look at the numbers in more
detail. So you see the clear Partizan divide
96 percent of Democrats have been vaccinated,
79 percent of independents have been vaccinated,
and a pathetic 54
Speaker 2: percent of Republicans
Speaker 1: have been vaccinated. Now, just as
interestingly, 30 percent of Republicans say they
will never get the vaccine. Another interesting
thing those who are not registered to vote.
Actually got vaccinated at a slightly higher rate
Speaker 2: than those who are
Speaker 1: registered
Speaker 2: to vote. That's
interesting. Also along educational
lines, there is a gap. 87 percent of those
Speaker 1: with a four year
degree have been vaccinated.
Only 73 percent of those without a four year
degree have been vaccinated, so not a big shock.
Speaker 2: Education leads to vaccination,
Speaker 1: just like education tends to lead
to people being more liberal, voting more
for Democrats than from Republicans. Now,
interestingly, there is almost no income gap
whatsoever. You might speculate you might not,
I don't know, but you might speculate that among
different income groups, you would see vaccination
Speaker 2: at different
Speaker 1: levels. The vaccine is
Speaker 2: free at the
Speaker 1: end user point, but maybe there would
be some reason why you'd see different levels of
vaccine uptake based on income. We don't see that
you make under 50k a year, 78 percent have been
vaccinated. If you make between 50 and 100k
Speaker 2: a year, 77
Speaker 1: percent have been vaccinated. I mean,
almost an identical number. Those making over
100k a year, 79 percent have been vaccinated.
Speaker 2: I mean, essentially no
Speaker 1: impact on vaccination
status based on income. So really
interesting numbers and also just
Speaker 2: stunningly low Republican
Speaker 1: vaccination. So at this point,
I don't know that the Republican Party cares about
the personal tragedy, the fact that way more of
their people are dying than others.
Speaker 2: I mean, after all,
it's all humans, right? Maybe they
Speaker 1: care. Maybe they don't want, I
don't know. Politically, this will
mean fewer Republicans around and alive
to vote in the midterms, particularly since it's
disproportionately voting age people that are
dying as a result of the virus now. Republicans
will still have gerrymandering working for them.
Republicans will still have voter suppression.
They'll have, you know, trying to use the courts,
all these different things that we've
seen them now try to do, but there will
be disproportionately fewer of them. Could it
affect close races? It's still really not clear.
You know, we ran the numbers. I'm going from
memory now, but we ran the numbers. Looking at Ron
DeSantis last gubernatorial win in Florida, he's
the very Trumpian Republican governor of Florida.
I I hope I'm getting this right. I think DeSantis
won by about 30 something thousand votes. And when
we looked at the deaths in Florida and started to
say, OK, if these are 60 40 Republican deaths, if
these are 65, 35 Republican deaths, could it make
a difference in the next gubernatorial election?
And the answer is it could. It's not an open
and shut case. There, there's a lot of caveats,
but the point is it's conceivable that the math
Speaker 2: would point that way on
Speaker 1: nonpartisan
Speaker 2: death gap
Speaker 1: alone. You could see. A case made
that it could lose the Florida governorship
for Republicans, so if that's conceivably
possible, certainly there are congressional
districts where the death cap on COVID could make
a difference. Whether they care about the people,
I don't know, but you'd think they
would at least care about elections.